You wake up on a strange heavenly body. You don't know where you are.
Luckily, you have on hand the following information:
You also have a knowledge of physics and plenty of rocks.
Your task is to find out where you are. Are you on earth, Mars, Pluto, Jupiter, or the moon?
Now, we see that you've plenty of rocks and the reason why this useful is
because you happen to know the fact about yourself.
You happen to know that on earth, the farthest you can throw a rock is 40 m. Not bad.
So you device a scheme, you decide to compare your abilities on earth
to your abilities on this new unknown location.
You find in this new unknown location, you can throw 250 m. This is the only thing I'll tell you.
From here you're on your own. Can you tell me which planet you're on?
And yes I know, the moon isn't really a planet and some people
will try to tell you Pluto wasn't either but don't listen to them.
If you're having trouble with this one, because I know this is a very
tricky problem, you can go into the forums and look for some help.